PROFESSOR: We just saw some
random variables come up
in the bigger number game.
And we're going to be talking
now about random variables,
just formally what they
are and their definition
of independence for
random variables.
But let's begin by looking
at the informal idea.
Again, a random variable
is a number that's
produced by a random process.
So a typical example
that comes up
where you get a random
variable is you've
got some system
that you're watching
and you're going to time it to
see when the next crash comes,
if it crashes.
So assuming that
this is unpredictable
that it happens in
some random way,
then the number of hours from
the present until the next time
the system crashes
is a number that's
produced by this
random process of
whether the system works or not.
Number of faulty
pixels in a monitor.
When you're building
the monitors
and delivering them to the
actual computer manufacturers,
there's a certain
probability that some
of the millions of pixels in the
monitor are going to be faulty.
And you could think of
that number of pixels
is also produced from an
unpredictable randomness
in the manufacturing process.
One that really is modeled
in physics as random
is when you have
a Geiger counter,
you're measuring
alpha particles.
The number of alpha
particles that
are detected by a given
Geiger counter in a second
is believed to be
a random number.
There's a distribution
that it has
but the number of
alpha particles
is not always the same
from second to second,
and so it's a random variable.
And finally, we'll look at
the standard abstract example
of flipping coins.
And if I flip coins
then the number
of heads in a given
number of flips--
let's say I flip a coin n times.
The number of heads
will be another rather
standard random variable.
OK what is abstractly
a random variable?
Oops, I'm getting
ahead of myself again.
Let's look at that example
of three fair coins.
So each coin has a probability
of being heads that's a half
and tails being a half.
I'm going to flip
the three of them.
And I'm going to assume that
they're distinguishable.
So there's a first coin, a
second coin, and a third coin.
Or alternatively you could think
of flipping the same coin three
times.
So the number of
heads is a number
that comes out of this random
process of flipping the three
coins.
So it's a number that's
either from 0 to 3.
There could be no
heads or all heads.
So it is a basic example
of a random variable
where you're producing
this integer based
on how the coins flip.
Another one is simply a
[? 0-1 ?] valued random
variable where it signals 1 if
all 3 coins match in what they
come up with, and 0
if they don't match.
Now once I have these
random variables defined,
one of the things
that's a convenient use
of random variables is
to use them to define
various kinds of events.
So the event that
C equals 1, that's
an event that-- it's
a set of outcomes
where the count is 1 and it
has a certain probability.
This is the event
of exactly 1 head.
There are 3 possible outcomes
among the 8 outcomes of heads
and tails with 3 coins.
So it has probability 3/8.
I could also just
talk about the outcome
that C is greater
than or equal to 1.
Well C is greater
than or equal to 1
when there is at least 1 head.
Or put another way, the only
time that C is not greater than
or equal to 1 is when
you have all tails.
So there's a 7/8 chance,
7 out of 8 outcomes
involve 1 or more heads.
So the probability that C
greater than or equal to 1
is 7/8.
Here's a weirder one.
I can use the two variables
C and M to define an event.
What's the probability that
C times M is greater than 0?
Well since C and M
are both non-negative
variables, the probability
that their product is greater
than 0 is equal to the
probability that each of them
is greater than 0.
OK, what does it mean
that M is greater
than 0 and C is greater than 0?
Well it says there's at
least 1 head-- that's
what C greater than 0 means.
And M greater than 0
means all the coins match.
This is an obscure way of
describing the event all heads,
and it has a course
probability 1/8.
Now we come to the
formal definition.
So formally, a random
variable is simply
a function that maps outcomes
in the sample space to numbers.
We think of the outcomes
in the sample space
as the results of a
random experiment.
They are an outcome and
they have a probability.
And when the outcome is
translated into a real number
that you think of
as being produced
as a result of that
outcome, that's
what the random variable does.
So formally, a random
variable is not a variable.
Or it's a function
that maps the sample
space to the real numbers.
And it's got to be
total, by the way.
It's a total function.
Usually this would be a
real valued random variable.
Usually it's the real numbers.
Might be a subset of the real
numbers like the integer valued
random variables.
Occasionally we'll use complex
valued random variables.
Actually, that happens
in physics a good deal
in quantum mechanics,
but not for our purposes.
We're just going to mean
real value from now on when
we talk about random variables.
So abstractly or intuitively
what the random variable
is doing really is it
just packaging together
in one object R,
the random variable,
a whole bunch of events that
are defined by the value
that R takes.
So for every possible real
number, if I look at the event
that R is equal to a,
that's an interesting event.
And it's one of the basic
events that R puts together.
And if you knew the
answer to all of these R
equals a's, then you
really know a lot about R.
And with this
understanding that R
is a package of
events of the form R
is equal to a, then a lot
of the event properties
carry right over to
random variables directly.
That's why this little topic
of introducing random variables
is also about independence
because the definition
of independence
carries right over.
Namely, a bunch of
random variables
are mutually independent if
the events that they define
are all mutually independent.
So if and only if the
events that are-- each event
defined by R1 and R2 and
through Rn, that set of events
are mutually independent
no matter what
the values are chosen that we
decide to look at for R1 and R2
through Rn.
And of course there's
an alternative way
we could always express
independent events
in terms of products instead
of conditional probabilities.
So we could say-- or
instead of invoking
the idea of mutual
independence we
could say explicitly where
it comes from as an equation.
It means that the probability
that R1 is equal to a1 and R2
is equal to a1 and
Rn is equal to an
is equal to the product
of the probabilities--
of the individual
probabilities--
that R1 is a1 times the
probability of R2 is a2.
And the definition then
of mutual independence
of the random
variables R1 through n,
Rn holds is that
this equation it
holds for all possible values,
little a1 through little an.
So let's just practice.
Are the variables C, which
is the count of the number
of heads when you flip
three coins, and M,
[? the 0-1 ?] valued random
variable that tells you whether
there's a match, are
they independent?
Well certainly not,
because there's definitely
a positive probability that
the count will be 1 that you'll
get at least a head.
And there's a
positive probability
that they all will match.
It's the probability
of a quarter.
So the product of
those 2 is positive,
but of course the probability
that you match and you'll
have exactly 1 head is 0 because
if you have exactly 1 head
you must have 2 tails
and there's no match.
So without thinking
very hard about what
the probabilities are
we can immediately
see that the product is not
equal to the probability
of the conjunction or the
and, and therefore they're
not independent.
Well here's one that's a
little bit more interesting.
In order to explain
it I've got to set up
the idea of an indicator
variable, which itself
is a very important concept.
So if I have an event
A, I can package A
into a random variable.
Just like the match random
variable was really packaging
the event that the coins
matched into a [? 0-1 ?] valued
variable, I'm going to define
the indicator variable for any
event A to be 1 if A occurs
and 0 if A does not occur.
So now I'm able to
capture everything
that matters about event A
by the random variable IA.
If I have IA I know what
A is, and if I have A I
know what IA is.
And it means that
really I can think
of events as special
cases of random variables.
Now when you do this
you need a sanity check.
Because remember we've
defined independence
of random variables one way.
I mean it's a concept
of independence that
holds for random variables.
We have another
concept of independence
that holds for events.
Now the definition
for random variable
was motivated by the
definition for events
but it's a different
definition of independence
of different kinds of objects.
Now if this correspondence
between events and indicator
variables is going to make
sense and not confuse us
it should be the case that
two events are independent if
and only if their indicator
variables are independent.
That is, IA and IB are
independent if and only
if the events A and
B are independent.
And this is a lovely
little exercise.
It's like a three-line
proof for you to verify.
I'm not going bother
to do it on the slide
because it's good practice.
So this would be a
moment to stop and verify
that using the two
definitions of independence,
the definition of what
it means for IA and IB
to be independent
as random variables
and comparing that to
the definition of what
it means for A and B to
be independent as events,
they match.
If we look at the event
of an odd number of heads
we can ask now
whether the event M,
which is the indicator
variable for a match--
the random variable M-- and
the indicator variable IO
are dependent or not.
Now both of these depend
on all the three coins.
IO is looking at
all 3 coins to see
if there are an odd
number of heads,
M is looking at all 3
coins to see if they're
all heads or all tails.
And it's not clear with all
that common basis for returning
what value they have.
It's not immediately obvious
that they're independent,
but as a matter
of fact they are.
And again this is
absolutely something
that you should check out.
If you don't stop the
video now to work it out,
you should definitely
do it afterward.
It's an important
little exercise
and it's easy to check.
All you have to do is check
that the probabilities
of the event of odd number of
heads in the event all match
are independent as events.
Or you could use the
random variable definition
and check that these two
random variables were
independent by
checking 4 equations
because this can
have values 0 and 1.
And this can have value 0 and 1.
Remember with independent
events we had the idea
that if A was independent
of B it really
meant that A was independent
of everything about B.
In particular it was independent
of the complement of B as well.
And a similar property
holds for random variables.
So intuitively if R
is independent of S
then R is really independent
of any information
at all that you have
about S. And that
can be made more
precise that R is
independent of any
information about S
by saying pick an arbitrary
function that maps R to R,
total function.
So what I can do is
think of f as giving me
some information
about the value of S.
So if R is independent
of S then in fact R
is independent of f of S,
any transformation of S
by a fixed non-random function.
And of course the notion
of k-way independence
carries right over
from the event case.
If I have k random-- if I have
a bunch of random variables,
a large number much
more than k, they're
k-way independent if
every set of k of them
are mutually independent.
And of course as with
events we use the 2-way case
to call them
pairwise independent.
Again, we saw an example of
this in terms of events already
but we can rephrase it now in
terms of indicator variables.
If we let Hi be the
indicator variable for a head
on a flip i-- of the
i flip of a coin--
where i ranges from 1
through k, if we have k coins
and Hi is the indicator
variable for how coin
I came out, whether
or not there's a head,
now O can be nicely expressed.
The notion that there's an
odd number of heads is simply
the mod 2 sum of the Hi's.
And this by the way, is a trick
that we'll be using regularly
that events now can be
defined rather nicely
in terms of doing
operations on the arithmetic
values of indicator variables.
So O is nothing
but the mod 2 sum
of the values of the indicator
variables Hi from 1 to k.
And what we saw when we were
working with their event
version is that any k of
these events are independent.
I've got k plus 1.
There's k Hi's and
there's O, which
makes the k plus
1-- k plus first.
[AUDIO OUT] And the reason why
any k of them were independent
was discussed in the previous
slide when we were looking
at the events of there
being an odd number of heads
and a head coming
up on the i flip.
The reason why pairwise
independence gets singled out
is that we'll see that for a
bunch of major applications
this pairwise
independence is sufficient
and rather than verifying
mutual independence.
It's harder to check
You've got a lot more
equations to check.
And in fact it often doesn't
hold in circumstances where
pairwise does hold.
So this is good to know.
We'll be making use of
it in an application
later when we look at sampling
and the law of large numbers.